j'ai un gros problème
oui on est moi déclaré revol je vous
écoute voilà hier soir on est allé au
bois comme d'habitude dans la nuit on se
fait voler nos corps j'ai vraiment les
croix ya des types qui tombent chez nous
sont repartis avec nos corps et nous on
a les leurs alors vous inquiétez pas on
pourra faire de l'art était venu
chercher
allo allo nino est devenu très dangereux
c'est lui qui détient mon corps j'ai
changé le monde n'est pas si vous voulez
les récupérer vous allez devoir vous
aider à l'arrêter quand même pas passer
toute ma vie dans ces corps de merde
tu t'appelles magali magail
mais où la gauche
ciao
magali est très importante elle est
puissant arrêter de parler d'elle comme
si c'était une arme c'est une enfant de
5 ans vous voyez pas elle a énormément
de bach mais c'est une enfant de 5 ans
quand même nous avons plus mais où est
ce que la menace d'un cran et on avait
dit qu'on l'a jour et calicots